in this video we're going to discuss
income inequality which is something
that is often debated thinking about
comparing countries thinking about
whether it's an issue or not and how to
address it and to appreciate what income
inequality is let's imagine two
different countries let's imagine first
country a and there's two people in
country a so you have person one here
who makes $1000 a year that's their
income and then there's person two in
country a that makes 99 thousand dollars
a year so what is going to be the
average income in country a if these are
the only two people you could think of
it as the per capita national income
well the average income here average
income to figure that out you would just
have to average the 1000 and the 99
thousand so you have a total income of
one plus ninety-nine a hundred thousand
and divided by two folks we're going to
have an average income of $50,000 per
year now let me construct another
country that has the same average income
but the distribution is very different
so in country B let's say the first
citizen of country B they make $50,000 a
year and let's say there's a second
person in country B and they also make
$50,000 per year per year well what's
the average income now well this is even
easier to compute 50 plus 50 divided by
2 your average income is $50,000 per
year so what you see here is two
countries that if you just looked at the
average income they seemed similarly
wealthy but that doesn't give you they
seem to have similar average income so
you say oh maybe they're similarly
prosperous but when you go a step deeper
you see that they are very different
country a is a lot more unequal than
country B when it comes
to income so question is is above and
beyond looking at things like average
income or average GDP or per capita GDP
how do you measure inequality and this
is something that this Italian
statistician Corrado Gini tried to
address and he comes up with something
called a Gini coefficient to measure
income inequality for a nation and the
way he approached it is actually pretty
intuitive what he did is he sets up two
axes so this axis right over here is
going to be the cumulative percentage of
the population so you start at 0% and
then you get all the way to hundred
percent of the population so this is the
cumulative percent of the population in
a country and then on this axis on this
axis you have the cumulative percentage
of the income in a country so this would
be zero down here and then this would be
hundred up here and so this is
cumulative percent of income in a
country and then he said well what would
a perfectly equal society look like when
a perfectly equal society as you add a
percentage on your cumulative percentage
of population you should add that exact
same percentage to your cumulative
percentage of income so as you go up you
really should just have a slope of 1
going up like this so one way to think
about it is when you're at 0 percent of
the population you should have 0 percent
of the income if you have a total of 10
percent of the population they should
have 10 percent of the national income
if you were to go to 50 percent of the
population which looks like it's around
there if it was perfectly distributed
the income well then that should be 50
percent of the national income but no
nation is actually there and so then we
have to think compare that to the
reality so let's say you look at a
country and and what you do is when
you're looking at the cumulative
percentage of the population you start
at the left with the lowest income and
as you add percentage of the population
you get to higher
in higher income folks so let's say
we're looking at a country that for the
poorest folks as you add percentages to
the cumulative population you're not
adding the same percent to the
cumulative income and so it might you
might have a curve that looks like this
and then as you add percentages in the
wealthier population for every 1% you
add you're adding more than 1% of
national income and so this curve
variety over here which you could view
is describing the reality for certain
nation this is known as a Lorenz curve
Lorenz curve and what Jeany said is well
the difference between the Lorenz curve
and this line right over here that that
would be a measure of income inequality
and so he would look at this area right
over here and say what percentage is
this area between this line and the
Lorenz curve what percentage is this of
this total area under the line and this
percentage is called the Gini
coefficient and it's typically quoted as
being a value from 0 to 1 or sometimes
you might see the scale as being from 0
to 100 so what would a Gini coefficient
of 0 represent well if you have a Gini
coefficient of 0 that means that this
area right over here between the Lorenz
curve and this line is 0 so that means
that we are dealing with a perfectly
equal income distribution so at the 0
end this is perfect equality perfect
income equality and then what is one or
a hundred mean that means that the area
between the line and the Lawrence curve
is a hundred percent of the area under
this line so that would look like
something like this a country whose
Lorenz curve looks like something like
this where all of these people I keep
adding more and more and more population
but I'm not adding more and more income
and then all of a sudden you get to the
very last person and then that
and as all of the income so that person
has all of the income well in that case
the Gini coefficient would be the
percentage of this area which would be
100% which we could view as a one or a
hundred and so an interesting thing to
do is is look at Gini coefficients for
various countries and compare them and
that's exactly what we have here on this
map and you can see that the the
countries that are shaded red these are
countries that have high Gini
coefficients so this is where you have
more income inequality and the ones that
are shaded green are the ones where you
have relatively low Gini indices or Gini
coefficients and so that would be
indicative of reasonably low income
inequality now it's important to point
out you might think that red is always
bad and green is always good but this
just tells you inequality it does not
tell you on average how prosperous folks
are what average income is in that
country and so this is an indication
that in places like Latin America and
sub-saharan Africa you definitely have
very high inequality and places like
Canada and Europe you seem to have a
very low inequality but it doesn't tell
you that people for sure are better off
in Canada than say the United States for
example you could have a higher average
income in the United States than you
have in Canada and one can have a very
spirited debate which one you would
rather be would you rather be in a
country that has higher inequality and
higher average income or one that has
lower income and lower inequality